hey what's going on everybody it's ETA
Prime back here again today we're going
to be taking a look at a pretty powerful
lowprofile single slot GPU that I
recently put together this is the
world's first single slot lowprofile Arc
A380 card and I'm really impressed by
the performance uh when it comes to the
form factor here and this is perfect for
those really small gaming PC builds
something similar to like the minus
Forum ms01 which has a really thin form
factor but a full-size PCI E slot inside
recently we got some new arc GP used
from a company known as Sparkle the A310
now this comes in with 4 gigs of vram
it's actually a pretty good little card
but it's very low power they also
released their lowprofile dual slot Arc
A380 which is one of my favorite cheaper
cards on the market right now especially
when it comes to these small form factor
builds and retail on this is around $119
but I have seen it come in at around 100
bucks in this video I'll show you
exactly what I did to make this a single
slot lowprofile A380 but before we jump
into it I do want to mention that this
video is brought to you by Ur CD Keys
I've actually been using this site for a
couple years now they do offer steam
Keys origin up play they even offer
Microsoft applications like office but
the main reason that I use Ur CD Keys is
for their Windows keys right now their
Windows 10 Pro OEM key is
$19.84 but if you use code ETA at
checkout you can get 25% off and another
great thing about buying from here is
they do accept Paypal I just did this
build here I need to activate Windows
I'm going to head over to my updates and
security we're going to go to
activation as you can see I've got
Windows 10 Pro but it's not activated so
I'm going to change product key I'm
going to paste it in here choose next
choose activate and windows is now
activated they'll email your code once
your payment is processed and that's
basically it if you're interested in
picking up cheap Windows 10 keys for
your new pc builds I'll leave a link in
the
description unfortunately at the time of
making this video nobody makes an
aftermarket lowprofile single slot
cooler for this A380 so what I had to do
here was pull the lowprofile single slot
cooler from the A310 and slap it right
on that A380 it actually fits on here
perfectly and we can go vice versa so
what I did was actually sell the A310
with the larger cooler to one of my
buddies for 60 bucks gave him a nice
little discount and if I was to buy
let's say an aftermarket cooler if
somebody created it for this I'd spend
around 80 to 100 bucks for that anyway
so the way I see it is I'm actually
coming out a bit cheaper but again
nobody makes an aftermarket cooler for
this A380 so I had to go this route and
with that A310 cooler it just doesn't
hit the vrm on the a380s board so I had
to add an aftermarket heat sink which
definitely does the job now this will
boost up to around 43 watts and you can
actually get more out of it with this
lowprofile cooler I've been able to go
up stably to around 52 Watts with higher
clocks and get some really great
performance now this definitely isn't
going to be for everybody and it'd be
really nice if an aftermarket company
came up with a solution for this some
type of copper heat sink that would fit
this lowprofile
A380 and one of the big reasons I wanted
to get this to a single slot form factor
was for these smaller PCS hit in the
market from companies like Min Forum
like the
ms01 so I personally love this little PC
here it's got a full size pcie 5.0 slot
inside but unfortunately you know you
can only go with a single slot
lowprofile card and now with the single
slot cooler on that A380 fits in here
perfectly now when they originally
showed off the ms01 on their YouTube
channel I'm talking about mines Forum
they showed off a low profile RTX A2000
now that did have a custom lowprofile
single slot cooler because that's all we
can fit in here and as soon as I can get
my hands on one I will be putting an RTX
A2000 in here it'll make a world of
difference but for now this is about the
most powerful single slot lowprofile
card that I can get to fit in this
unit all right so here it is as you can
see we've got the I9 13900 and this ms01
from Min Forum 32 gigs of ddr5 at 5200
megat transfers per second and of course
we've got that Arc A380 with that low
profile single slot cooler again does
come low profile but it's a dual slot
setup with this cooler we can fit it
perfectly inside of the ms01 and we got
6 gigs of vram with this unit at out of
the box this sparkle A380 actually
performs pretty well and from art
control panel we can go to Performance
Tuning and from here we can go all the
way up to 43 WTS we've also got a GPU
performance boost and a GPU voltage
offset so I do like doing a little bit
of tweaking but since we've got this
smaller cooler on it I don't know how
far we can go over 43 Watts but I have
found kind of a hack for these
cards basically even though we're
running this at 43 Watts we can clock a
lot higher than these stock clocks from
Sparkle and in order to enable this what
I've been using is the Predator bifrost
software we can actually trick this card
into thinking we can go up a bit higher
here so maximum clock with this A380 low
profile is 1,900 36 MHz okay I mean it
does perform pretty well but if I trick
this into thinking that we're in kind of
turbo mode with a different card we can
boost up a bit higher now we're not
going to be doing 235 Watts with this so
I've created custom profile just up to
54 Watts we've got our temperature set
at 90° C that's kind of the maximum
we're going to go before it starts
underclocking itself and now if I run
fur Mark just go ahead and get this
going you can see that our GPU clock
does boost up a bit higher and we're
sitting around 52 Watts on that tgp GPU
temp does climb up there but I haven't
hit over 82° Celsius with this card yet
and of course it is a low profile in
this small form factor case not too bad
and right now this is more of an extreme
test but yeah we can get those higher
clocks on this A380 by using the bifrost
software and this does come in handy but
uh you know if you wanted to keep it at
the stock clocks you definitely could
and now what I wanted to do was move
over to some benchmarks to show you how
this thing
performs first up we've got 3D Mark
night raid and I've really never been
impressed with the a380s uh score as we
get out of here coming in at
28,9 66 definitely not going to win any
awards here but moving over to fire
strike does jump up a bit to
9,694 and finally we've got time spy
with a
4,485 when you compare this to other
single Slot lowprofile Cards on the
market that are affordable this is
definitely coming out ahead even the RX
6400 which was the original card I
wanted for this little unit here
unfortunately it just doesn't perform
like I wanted it to but with all of
these new Intel Arc drivers we're seeing
some pretty decent performance out of
the
A380 but these are syn benchmarks and
now it's time to see how this thing
handles real world gaming and the first
one we have here is Hell divers 2 1080p
low with XC SS set to Balan this is one
of those games I would suggest going
down to 900p you can do medium settings
with no xcss but even at 1080 low
settings it's definitely a playable
experience on this little PC we're
seeing averages of around 81
FPS next up power world 1080p low medium
mix had to go through through kind of
adjust everything and we're seeing an
average of around 64 now at the time of
making this video power world doesn't
have XS built-in from the factory you
will have to mod it even FSR would have
helped out with this but unfortunately
you know stock we only have access to
dlss moving over to Mortal Kombat 1
1080p medium XC SS set to Balan seeing
some decent performance here with
fighting games I've been able to run
Street Fighter 6 obviously Mortal Kombat
1 and even Tekken 8 at full speed medium
settings Borderlands 3 1080p medium
settings uh this little AR card does
perform quite well with this game I know
it's a bit older but it's still a lot of
fun to play we got an average of around
84 FPS with this at 100% resolution
scale medium settings so yeah I mean
this is another one that's going to be
fully playable on a little card like
this and if you take a look at the temps
we're only up to around 72° C on that
GPU would be nice to see lower temps but
we're not thermal throttling this thing
at
all fortnite 1080p medium settings uh I
don't play this so I'm not exactly sure
really what to test here but uh on
average we're seeing around 86 FPS I
kind of suspected we'd see some decent
performance out of this game
here of course I had to throw in fors
Horizon 5 one of my go-to tests we're at
1080p high no resolution scale so we
didn't need to enable Xs and you know if
you wanted to go up with the resolution
you could probably hit 1440p with this
card adding some X SS but then it's kind
of null because I'd say 1080 High
settings does look really great like it
is God of War 1080p original settings
this actually performed much better than
I thought it would on this Arc card but
recently we did get an update from Intel
newer drivers here didc performance
across the board with these Arc gpus and
God of
War and the final game we have here is
cyberpunk 2077 this is one that's always
struggled on these art cards even the
higher end cards it's gotten a lot
better over the last few months and
right now we are at 1080p medium
settings with XS set to Performance if
you don't mind going down the low
settings you can get an average of
around 89 FPS with it like this or go
down the low and take that scaling up to
balance which will clean it up a bit
either way it's still a playable
experience on this lowprofile A380 with
that single slot cooler installed and
again highest temps that I saw was 76° C
out of this card through all of my
testing so yeah for these smaller form
factor thin belts like the ms01 adding
something like this really does help out
with GPU performance but it's not for
everybody because of course we don't
have an aftermarket cooler that's easily
accessible now one thing that I did was
take the A310 swap the coolers between
the two and then sold my A310 for 60
bucks I'm not exactly sure how well
something like that would sell over on
eBay but there might be a market for it
and if you've got a buddy who needs a
lower profile card with not as much
power as that A380 then this could be a
good option for you but that's going to
wrap it up for this video if you've got
any questions let me know in the
comments below I'll also leave some
links to where you can pick these up
unfortunately you will have to buy both
cards up front to get this working but
you know for some people they might want
to go ahead and do something like this
if you want to see anything else tested
with this card let me know in the
comments and like always thanks for
watching